You might be wondering where I found the value sets for
RIM codes over on the FHIR website.
Earlier, I said that FHIR builds on existing standards.
And that is true for RIM as well but with exceptions.
Scope. It should be clear by now that the goal
of RIM is comprehensive representation of the health care domain.
FHIR resources represent only those data elements
that are expected to be used by most implementations.
FHIR uses an 80% rule.
If approximately 80% of systems using resource will support a particular data element,
then it is part of the core standard.
A specific subdomain can add other elements as needed using FHIR extensions.
FHIR profiles both constrain resources for
use case and define extensions appropriate to specific subdomains.
Source of data elements.
All data elements in HL7 v3 instances come from either the RIM or
data types developed by the International Organization for Standardization or ISO, I-S-O.
In FHIR, this is true of most but not all resources and data type elements.
Some FHIR resources deal with content that is outside of the RIM scope.
And in a few instances,
FHIR adjust data types to accommodate issues not yet supported in RIM.
Nuance. As you've seen,
RIM attempts to convey the meaning of instances through attributes like the mood code.
FHIR codes are generally limited to attributes with a rather concrete business meaning.
Finally, in FHIR, a value set is just another type of
resource that can be sent as part of an instance just like any other piece of data.
As a result, although FHIR uses RIM data elements,
it's possible to implement FHIR with absolutely no knowledge of the HL7 RIM.
This greatly facilitates rapid development.